bonjour va s'employer bonjour nicolas
vous êtes bénévole pour l'association
rencontres pour l'égalité d'accès à
l'emploi et vous être un coach pour la
préparation à l'entretien d'embauché
exactement alors je recherche
actuellement un emploi dans le marketing
j'ai construit mon cv comment je dois
aborder un entretien d'embauché
alors pour moi il faut aborder
l'entretien d'embauché en fonction du
poste que l'on recherche
je vois que tu es tu cherches un poste
de chargé d'études en marketing soit il
est important de connaître
l'annnonce du cos sur lequel on postule
de repérer dans les missions du poste 2
3 4 critères clés 3 4 mo pectine ans qui
sont dans la noce et dans sa
présentation
tu reprends au travers de thé expérience
ces trois ou quatre mots je sais pas sur
un poste de chargé d'études en marketing
certainement qu'il est nécessaire
d'avoir le sens de l'organisation
l'important c'est que toi tu puisse
présenter une expérience une réussite
dans ton parcours professionnel où tu as
fait preuve de sens de l'organisation
le plus concret possible vraiment
rentrer dans les détails pour que ça
apparaisse vraiment comme vécu comme
vécu et comme une réussite
le principe même d'un recruteur pour moi
c'est que ce qu'un candidat
une personne a déjà su faire a déjà
réalisé elle sera le réaliser à nouveau
alors là vous donner justement vous
venez de donner l'exemple d'une personne
qui expérimentait mais imaginions que je
n'avais pas d'expérience et que
finalement j'étais faut uniquement sur
mes qu'on peut faire valoir mes diplômes
comment j'aurais fait ce que j'aurais pu
insister peut-être sûrement savoir être
sur ton savoir être sur tes expériences
autres pas forcément professionnel tu as
peut-être des passions tu as peut-être
fait du sport tu as peut-être et étaient
donc des associations et ça ça permet de
valoriser des savoir être
ça peut être la capacité relationnelle
l'écoutent l'organisation le travail en
équipe
voilà merci vincent employés pour ses
conseils